leinders tchad et nick et l'illustrateur
montréalais pas tabou dessine des
affiches de spectacles pour les plus
grandes stars de la planète
son objectif traduire la musique en
images un caractère du du groupe que
j'essaye de mettre dans le dans la fiche
c'est pas comme deux images qui ne
m'arrive pas vraiment et puis turin tu
mets le nom de groupe puis c'est fini
souvent ce sont les maisons de disques
et la gérance qui contrôlent l'image des
groupes mais certains artistes insiste
pour être impliqué directement
il ya beaucoup de musiciens qui comme
jacques wade est très il regarda tous
les sketchs et te demandent de faire des
changements personnellement un tarif à
beaucoup ça alors c'est cool quand
l'artiste directement est engagé at-on
travail
le virage numérique n'a pas diminué la
popularité des posteurs musicaux les
ventes de disques se sont effondrées
c'est bien qu'une part importante des
revenus de l'industrie vient des
concerts les affiches sont précieuses
pour annoncer les spectacles sur la rue
pour affirmer la présence des groupes en
ligne ou encore comme produits dérivés
vendus durant le concert certains fans
et collectionneurs sont prêts à dépenser
des fortunes pour acquérir des affiches
des gros qu'ils apprécient et parce
qu'on n'arrête pas le progrès mais
maintenant des applications qui
permettent de voir les affiches en
réalité augmentée énormément des revues
l'organisme arc montréal archives de
nombreuses affiches de groupes et
d'artistes locaux très important pour
jusqu'à main d'oeuvre comme une image
mais comme une source d'information
surtout dans notre milieu de la musique
et de l'art de la culture un peu en deux
groupes un peu sur les marges
parfois la seule trace d'un activité une
exposition d'un concert
j'existe et un tract où on affiche qu'on
peut retrouver en réaction à la
démocratisation des outils d'impression
et de dessin informatique
on assiste depuis une dizaine d'années
une renaissance des affiches artisanale
sérigraphié ou faites à la main la
création d' affiches permet aux artistes
d'expérimenter et de bonifier leurs
pratiques
c'est le cas de jason cantoro un artiste
montréalais qui connaît un succès
croissant
à force d'apprendre comment faire la
belle sirène graphie avec sa pratique de
la fiche mais la céni a commencé à faire
des oeuvres c'est l'expérience et la
pratique qui peuvent jouer avec toutes
sortes de formes
quand on donne un contre un et
affichiste on dit pas toujours
exactement qu'est ce qu'on veut au
dessus il peut utiliser sa tête un
laboratoire c'est la création d'un fish
à montréal reste très dynamique et tout
indique qu'elle a encore de beaux jours
devant elle les poseurs musicaux sont là
pour rester et pour coller ici nabi
alexandre charti radio canada montréal